[Music]
welcome and we are live I just want to
show you just briefly this is the
Sentinel this is the Interceptor and
this is the assault fighter and what
each one of these is actually using is
we kind of just generated some different
looks just to start things off it's a
prototype okay but what I can do is also
cycle between the different looks of
these modular ships that all have like
different wings and different engines
different bodies associated with them
and this is how we are able to generate
a lot of different player ships that
will be available in the full game so
I'm actually going to use this guy
that's that guy right there good so so
yeah so just want to show you that
little thing no I love it now knows Ross
customization do we get any can we get
likes Lizzie without paint jobs and do
that or we lock good right I think the
big thing it's gonna be similar to what
we do with our space one where we have a
primary and secondary and a tertiary
color object so that way you have that
customization but it's also not gonna be
it's not gonna be like super crazy I can
paint whatever the heck that I want the
ships are realistic unreal looking real
sex and being really excited about
colors space a little bit is beautiful
thank you
so there's a lot of different ways to
engage your foes I'm just gonna do the
standard use a pulse laser he's gonna
try and dodge around a little bit now
I'm noticing numbers on enemies so I'm
gonna assume that there's certain
enemies from a leveling standpoint that
we can handle with it maybe some we
cannot handle with absolutely correct
yeah the lovely progression system that
were that we're adding is gonna help
make certain levels more challenging
versus some areas easier so you can kind
of pick and choose do you really want to
pick that big fight or do you want to
kind of go a little bit smoother in your
travel times just go oh oh just grab
this fuel can can stir and we're gonna
try and see if we can hit this drone
maybe we can oh we went too far the fact
that you could even do that we have this
nice little grapple mechanic this time
around where you can interact with
certain objects and have some fun fire
this is just keyboard mouse and
controller or do you have joysticks or
joystick support is definitely a thing
we have controllers not only but then
also like all types of botas a lot of
people out there HOTAS so when you're
going into space of course we make
access key double joy success or just a
single like that's a good question I
want to say yes but I'm not actually
sure it's something we could look into
alright so with the handcrafted
environments that we're flying around
there's also secrets that were able to
plug in so we're able to find this this
energy core and this explosive plating
which is a great point to show you a
little bit of the Diablo loo yeah so
each one of these has just a different
attribute associated with it you have
six different attributes on your
character much like six different
attributes of the Dungeons & Dragons
character right so in the case of these
it's not too much of a bonus but it's
something extra so we have more armor
now more structure we have more repair
and the energy course is giving us a
little bit higher capacity and recharge
grades not anything substantial but if
we were to find something that was not
just superior but something that was
rare or maybe something exotic or
legendary I'll go to the Destiny space I
like this talk but the show so then we
could start finding some attributes that
change everything that maybe we have an
energy core that adds a substantial
amount to your handling so all of a
sudden now and you want to do like a
barrel roll you can spin like the
dickens so right what's cool let the
loop variation is really going to open
up the possibilities of your gameplay
style and what you like to do based on
what loot you get right absolutely is
that green almost like a flag like their
faction based or how did how is that so
the factions yeah so each of the
factions does have kind of like a unique
call sign insignia bound to them so
you're gonna know this is the property
of the coalition oh this is the property
of the G and B oh this is not really a
faction owned by anybody they're just
kind of like scoundrels that are just
operating schedule
yeah just sheer scoundrels right what I
want to show you here just very briefly
was that we have this action freeze sort
of system where you can pause and just
take your own shop so whatever is going
on and unreal that's right and we we do
have other modifiers - you can actually
see them changing the depth of field
here so we can get we get all types of
sexy shots that's five so we have the
action shots our camera move okay
yeah I think we could just resume right
where we left off we'll actually have
more to talk about with the action
freeze later because there may or may
not be more coming to it okay this is
I'm really digging it and again I see I
see you putting up little shields what
about basic controls you got your
shields you got your blasters that kind
of thing you got we got our hyperspace
that we're clearly doing right now to
unload location so now we're actually
leaving the location entirely because we
didn't like that battle we wanted to go
explore somewhere else so you can
actually see we're moving away from that
planet that we were just at so we are we
are flying we're flying entirely in this
region all of this is over where we can
just kind of go wherever we want doing
everyone fine with the Mass Effect style
map that I like and so through this area
we could encounter unknown signals and
travel to in your location or we can
just say like I want to fly to the star
that's Auto piloting now if I don't want
to wait you know what that's fine I'm
just gonna hold down this R button and
oh there it so it's you know we have
this fast-paced nature of the game we
just want to make sure that it continues
to be fast paced we don't want you to
wait around if you don't want to be able
to give it a anyway if you want to take
that leisurely stroll across the stars
by all means
so nice if we got that this was kind of
like what I call the Wing Commander
stuff well you got you know your MPC
talking to you while it's going on voice
acting on on I am particularly drawn to
that level of stuff so tell us about
that scientists and what do you know
these guys are trying to tell you while
you're doing your missions so this this
scientists particular he's actually in
this location he's saying hey I need
some help because my solar panels got
all messed up and I need you to fix them
and I'm willing to pay you if you help
me out I actually ignored them if we
wanted to we can go talk to him and we
could complete that mission gotcha and
there's gonna be a lot of different
characters that you encounter in the
world that will provide those different
opportunities to you should you take a
month sometimes they might not be
opportunities sometimes there might be
traps after all this is a continuation
of a story and your character may or may
not be well known in this area gotcha
let me ask you this a question on again
story beat sounds great progression now
on their losses oh my goodness I need to
travel to another location for that I
think that would be a lot of fun to show
you got these cool dogfights these cool
enemies but you know be cool to take on
some challenging things for us and yeah
we had a lot of larger ships and ever
space one we want to take that and just
take it to the next level really so what
we're doing is we're making an
assortment of medium sized enemies two
ones that are so large that when you
engage them you can fly inside of a lot
of possibilities that fire
check out this little guy actually it
looks like the G and B this faction
nearby they don't actually like our laws
at all
Wow so they're just assailing them from
afar hopefully they don't shoot us a
little bit right now can you change your
relationship with factions you can't and
that's gonna be through just kind of
like decisions you make jobs that you
pick up and where you're going
it's not anything super crazy deep I do
want to put emphasis on that just
because like a disk or this is an arc ad
space shooter this is not a simulation
this is not something where you need to
manage like 50 different thousand not
systems to like figure out how do I
tweak and modify these relationships do
I need to like buy a cup of coffee for
this guy you know you don't need to do
that we're not going to pull out or the
outer worlds route right it's it's very
simple v to like if you want a better
your relationship with somebody using
the complete jobs for them if you want
to hinder that you take a job and then
you don't complete it or you just trade
a pataga
like that's that's going to be most of
the given hall of these relationships
and those relationships do open up and
close opportunities to
nice so this guy coming through through
warp gate this is an outlaw destroyer
one type of larger enemies that you're
going to be encountering now I'm
shooting a pulse laser at him and it's
doing like barely any damage and that's
because the pulse laser deals much more
energy damage as opposed to kinetic
damage and each of these different types
of DPS are going to be more beneficial
to use versus types of enemies
essentially Energy's great against
shields connects great against armor
gotcha
so I want to change over to this
autocannon which is gonna plow right
through this armor and now I'm hitting
this hole and he's going down but we're
still taking little damage right yeah so
he opened up these coils which do
tremendous damage to it until he closes
those coils and gains armor back so
there are weak points that you can fit
boss mechanics that's right so you have
these weak points that you can figure
out and target even like these turrets
if they take enough damage they'll
actually go into the ship to repair as
you can see right there so depending on
how you engage you're gonna have new
opportunities just in a single ship
engagement like the aya
this is super impressive that just you
shooting the coils I'm blown away by the
LA okay let's do it one more time maybe
we can take this guy off his English
although like look at his health go down
all beautiful
look at the destruction Wow beautiful
he's breaking the breezeway all the
detail everybody watchin out though this
is still working progress did that look
easy yes was it easy yes will it be like
that in the full game we're gonna
challenge people for sure so you will be
rewarded for your accomplishments looks
absolutely spectacular on the backdrops
to plan it this is again this is for the
for the rkd shooter but also the Diablo
loot mechanics the factions this story
you got a lot going on ever verse to
bellick we're really excited man I
cannot wait for release so again any
other questions you got look me you're
impressed
I'm good I'm impressed I I love seeing
how the graphics are all it's starting
we cannot wait for release again an
absolute pleasure ever verse too early
but hopefully coming up on a Kickstarter
and then and then release hopefully your
early access will be end of the year in
September it's 100% locked in place it's
not changing with the for release out
one year after that you heard it here
first have rock fish games with another
one man absolute pleasure thank you so
much my question absolutely
[Music]